IN FOCUS OFF THE TOP OF THIS
HOUR OF "THE FAULKNER FOCUS"
I’M HARRIS FAULKNER.
MY GUEST IN FOCUS ARI FLEISCHER
FORMER WHITE HOUSE PRESS
SECRETARY AND FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR.
IT WAS QUITE A WIND-UP.
NOT EVERYBODY CAN HEAR THE
QUESTIONS BEING SHOUTED.
WE COULD CLEARLY HEAR THE
RESPONSE FROM THE PRESIDENT.
>> HIS COMMUNICATIONS TEAM IS
HIGH FIVING EACH OTHER.
LIKE HE STAYS ON MESSAGE AND
DOESN’T WANT TO TALK ABOUT
AFGHANISTAN.
ADD IT ALL UP.
JOE BIDEN IS A TROJAN HORSE
WITH A SCRIPT.
HIS OPENING, EVERYTHING HE
TALKED ABOUT WAS A PROGRESSIVE
LIBERAL SPENDING SPREE THAT HAD
NOTHING TO DO WITH COVID,
NOTHING TO DO WITH JOBS.
IT IS JUST LIBERAL WISH LIST
COME TRUE.
AND I CAN TELL YOU THIS.
IF DONALD DUCK WERE THE
PRESIDENT YOU WOULD HAVE THE
SAME JOB NUMBERS YOU HAVE
BECAUSE COVID HAS BEEN DEFEATED.
IT WASN’T BECAUSE OF BIDEN AND
THE JOBS PLAN BUT AMERICANS
COMING BACK TO WORK.
THEY’RE COME BACK TO WORK
SLOWER BECAUSE OF THE EXCESS
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS PEOPLE
ARE GETTING.
ADD IT ALL UP, THE WAY HE
LOOKED AT HIS NOTES.
THE WAY HE HAD IT ON THE CARD.
READ FROM HIS SCRIPT.
HE IS A TROJAN HORSE WITH A
SCRIPT.
THAT’S MY SUMMARY.
>> Harris: THE PROBLEM FOR THE
MEDIA IN THE ROOM.
THEY CAN SAY WHAT THEY WANT
ABOUT FOX NEWS.
THOSE REPORTERS WEREN’T ALL
FROM FOX NEWS AND HUNGRY FOR
THE TRUTH WHICH MIGHT HAVE BEEN
A REFRESHING DIFFERENCE FOR
SOME AND SURPRISE FOR PRESIDENT
BIDEN.
WE DON’T GET HIS CARDS.
SO WHEN HE STARTS TO LOOK DOWN
AND GO FROM THE CARDS WE DON’T
HAVE THAT.
THAT’S AN EXCELLENT THING.
I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT REALLY
WHERE HE WAS THERE IN THE TALK
ABOUT JOBS.
I WANT TO DRILL DOWN TO WHERE
THE NATION REALLY IS.
HE SAID WELL, WE’VE CREATED 3
MILLION JOBS SINCE JANUARY.
THAT’S AN AMAZING GREAT THING.
PEOPLE AREN’T JUMPING TO TAKE
THEM.
>> THE REASON JOBS ARE BEING
CREATED IS BECAUSE COVID IS
OVER.
JOE BIDEN DIDN’T END COVID.
THE VACCINES ENDED COVID.
AND IF ANY CREDIT IS TO BE
GIVEN IT WAS AS A RESULT OF THE
PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION, THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION THAT
ACCELERATED THE PRODUCTION OF
THESE VACCINES AND JOE BIDEN IS
THE LUCKY BENEFICIARY OF THAT.
SO THAT’S WHY.
IT’S INEVITABLE AND NATURAL
PEOPLE GO BACK TO WORK WHEN THE
LOCKDOWNS END AND PEOPLE FEEL
SAFER BECAUSE THEY’RE
VACCINATED.
HE TAKES CREDIT WHICH IS WHAT
ALL POLITICIANS DO.
THEY SAY IT’S ALL THE RESULT OF
THEIR PLAN AND IT NEVER IS.
IT’S NEVER 100% THAT.
THERE MAYBE A TINY ELEMENT OF
SOMETHING.
THAT’S WHAT A TYPICAL
POLITICIAN DOES AND WHAT JOE
BIDEN IS DOING.
I’M GLAD TO SEE HOW REPORTERS
FOUND THEIR OWN VOICE A LITTLE
BIT AND STARTED TO PEPPER HIM
ABOUT AFGHANISTAN AND OTHER
TOPICS.
THAT’S THE USUAL CAT AND MOUSE
GAME BETWEEN THE WHITE HOUSE
PRESS CORPS.
THEY’RE STILL TOO SOFT AND
FRIENDLY TO JOE BIDEN BUT THEY
FOUND THEIR VOICE ON OTHER
QUESTIONS TODAY.
>> Harris: A START IS A START
IS A START I SUPPOSE.
LET’S GO QUICKLY ABOUT THE JOBS.
IF YOU CONTINUE TO PAY THOSE
WAITING.
IT WILL ONLY LAST UNTIL
SEPTEMBER.
PEOPLE WILL HAVE  GO AND FIND A
JOB.
THE DOLE WON’T BE THERE FOREVER.
LAST QUICK THOUGHT ON THAT.
>> BURIED IN THE NUMBERS IS
CALLED THE LABOR FORCE
PARTICIPATION RATE AND AT A LOW
LEVEL DOWN TO 61%.
TYPICALLY IT’S UP TO 63 TO 64%
LEVEL.
THE DIFFERENCE IS MASSIVE.
IT MEANS PEOPLE AREN’T
PARTICIPATING IN LOOKING FOR
JOBS.
THEY’RE HAPPY TO STAY AT HOME
AND THEY DON’T COUNT AS BEING
PART OF UNEMPLOYED BECAUSE THEY
AREN’T LOOKING FOR WORK.
WHY?
THEY DON’T NEED TO.
THEY GET THEIR EXCESSIVE
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFIT CHECK
WHICH IN SOME STATES CAN BE
$40,000 A YEAR.
MUCH OF IT -- A PORTION TAX
FREE TO STAY AT HOME AND
COLLECT UNEMPLOYMENT.
THAT’S THE PROBLEM, HARRIS.
>> Harris: LET’S GET TO THIS.
THE WHITE HOUSE IS MULTI-TASK
TODAY.
THEY’RE TRYING NOW TO PROTECT
VICE PRESIDENT KAMALA HARRIS
AFTER THE BOMBSHELL CLAIMS OF
AN ABUSIVE WORK ENVIRONMENT.
A TOP BIDEN AIDE IS CALLING IT
SABOTAGE.
A "POLITICO" REPORT ON THE
INFIGHTING IN HER OFFICE WITH
THIS HEADLINE.
NOT A HEALTHY ENVIRONMENT.
KAMALA HARRIS’S OFFICE  REIFF
WITH DISSENT.
>> AIDS AND ADD MIN TRAITION
OFFICIALS SAY AND IT IS
EMANATING FROM THE TOP.
CEDRIC RICHMOND TOLD AXIOS IT
IS A WHISPER CAMPAIGN DESIGNED
TO SABOTAGE HER.
IT DOESN’T HAVE TO BE CREDIBLE.
OKAY, SO WHEN YOU READ THE
REPORT BEFORE THIS JOB SHE WAS
A.G. OF CALIFORNIA.
SHE HAS BEEN A SENATOR.
THERE WERE 22 PEOPLE ALONG THE
WAY, INCLUDING THOSE WHO ARE
CURRENTLY WITH HER.
THAT’S NOT ONE PERSON SPREADING
A GOSSIP WORD, ARI.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF IT?
>> FIRST I GUESS WHISPER
CAMPAIGN IS THE BIDEN WORD FOR
FAKE NEWS SO CHALK THAT UP.
LOOK, ANY TIME I READ A STORY
THAT HAS JUST ANONYMOUS SOURCES
MY REACTION IS I’M GOING TO
WAIT TO SEE IF IT COMES TRUE.
MAYBE IT’S TRUE, SOMETIMES IT
IS.
SOMETIMES IT’S NOT.
THAT WAS MY STANDARD FOR
READING STORIES ABOUT DONALD
TRUMP THAT I THOUGHT IT WAS
UNFAIR THEY QUOTE ANONYMOUS
PEOPLE AND I WILL ADHERE TO
THAT STANDARD IN THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
IS IT TRUE?
IT WAS THE CASE IN HER SENATE
OFFICE AND PRIMARY CAMPAIGN.
BUT THESE STAFF THINGS, IT’S
ABOUT THE PERSON, NOT ABOUT THE
STAFF AND WHEN THEY HAVE A HARD
JOB BUT IS SHE DOING A GOOD JOB?
THIS IS WHERE JOE BIDEN PICKED
HER SO IF THEY DON’T LIKE THE
JOB SHE IS DOING THE FAULT LIES
WITH JOE BIDEN.
I DO THINK SHE HASN’T DONE A
GOOD JOB AT VICE PRESIDENT.
THE WAY SHE HAS HANDLED THINGS
RAISES QUESTIONS WHETHER SHE IS
READY FOR THIS JOB.
WHETHER SHE IS SERIOUS ENOUGH.
AND SHE SEEMS TO JUST WING IT.
YOU CAN’T WING IT EITHER AS A
SENATOR OR AS A VICE PRESIDENT
CERTAINLY NOT AS A PRESIDENT.
THAT’S WHAT SHE SEEMS TO BE
DOING.
>> Harris: I REMEMBER WATCHING
THE ZOOM EARLY IN JOE BIDEN’S
PRESIDENCY AND HE HAD ALL THESE
EMPLOYEES ON AND HE SAID IF
ANYBODY MISTREATS ANYBODY HE
WOULD PERSONALLY FIRE THEM.
SO IF THERE IS ANY TRUTH TO ANY
OF THIS IT WILL BE INTERESTING
TO SEE HOW THE PRESIDENT OF THE